[Music]
with the jury in the oculus ZeniMax
lawsuit having rendered its verdict an
oculus ordered to pay 500 million
dollars needless to say oculus exec and
eggs animax employee John Carmack is
pissed I mean I would be too if I
personally had to pay 50 million to my
ex-employer but Carmack believes a
particular expert was imprudent during
the trial I'm Lucy and welcome to your
objection gamespot news updates he wrote
on Facebook the ZeniMax vs oculus trial
is over I disagreed with their
characterization misdirection and
selective omissions I never tried to
hide or wipe any evidence and all of my
data is accounted for contrary to some
stories being spread being sued sucks
for the most part the process went as I
expected Carmack took issue with one
particular element which was the
testimony of an expert than ZeniMax
brought to the trial specifically
Carmack objected to the experts at said
oculus as implementations of the
techniques at issue were non literally
copied from the source code I wrote
while in software Carmack claims this is
just not true the authors oculus never
had access to the ed C++ br code only a
tiny bit of plaintext shader code from
the demo early on in his testimony I
wanted to stand up say sir as a man of
computer science I challenge you to
defend the efficacy of your methodology
with data including false positive and
negative rates after he had said he was
absolutely certain there was non-literal
copying in several cases I just wanted
to shout you lie by the end after seven
cases of absolutely certain I was
wondering if gangsters had kidnapped his
grandchildren and were holding them for
ransom how that goes on to suggest the
testimony would not have stood out if
the experts phrasing had been different
he also describes the expert presenting
slide that couldn't be properly read
when the defense later enlarge them for
the jury to better see them it didn't
demolish the credibility of the testim
carmack at hope he said notably I wasn't
allowed to read the full expert report
only listened to him in trial and even
his expert testimony in trial is under
seal rather than in the public record
this is surely intentional if the code
examples were really publicly the
internet would have viciously mock the
analysis I still have a level of morbid
curiosity about the several hundred page
report ZeniMax is now responded to calm
exposed reiterating certain findings
from the case in addition to expert
testimony finding both literal and
non-literal copying oculus programmers
themselves admitted using ZeniMax is
copyrighted code one saying he cut and
pasted it into the oculus SDK and
brenton air be in writing requested a
license for the source code shared by
Carmack they needed for the oculus rift
not surprisingly the jury found ZeniMax
code copy rights were infringed the
oculus rift was built on a foundation of
ZeniMax technology as for the denial of
wiping the court independent expert
found ninety-two percent of carmax hard
drive was white all data was permanently
destroyed right after Carmack got notice
of the lawsuit and that his affidavit
denying the wiping was false those are
the hard facts ouch whose side are you
on let me know in the comments below for
more on the ZeniMax oculus lawsuit make
sure to LIKE this video and subscribe to
games watch on youtube
[Music]